In the old days,
games were written to run on
one particular model of computer or
gaming hardware.
These days,
people will play games on any device
they can cram a microcontroller into.
There's still dedicated gaming hardware,
like handhelds and
consoles, but there's also mobile phones
running primarily Android and iOS.
There's desktop computers running Mac,
Windows, and Linux.
And, of course,
there's the bane of middle school
productivity browser based games.
With this wealth of gaming platforms,
the issue arises that
all these platforms use different
programming languages and
different systems for drawing,
networking, input, and
pretty much everything else,
including in what form that these
applications take when they're
actually distributed to end users.
For instance,
Android apps are written in Java and
get packaged into an APK archive for
a distribution.
iOS apps are written in a completely
different language, in Objective-C or
more recently in Swift.
iOS apps then get packaged into
an IPA file for distribution.
Web apps are a really complicated and
diverse beast.
But the code that actually runs
the game on the client side needs to
be in JavaScript or a language
that compiles down to JavaScript.
Then to distribute your web app to the
servers that are going to run it there
are a ton of different ways to do it,
one of which is a web archive file.
Desktop apps can be even more diverse
and can be written in any language that
runs on a desktop computer,
which is pretty much all of them.
For distribution, there are a ton
of options, including EXE files for
Windows, JARs that are executable jars,
DMG disk images for
Mac or really anything else.
As an indie developer, you would
like to make cross-platform games so
that you can distribute your awesome new
game on as many platforms as possible.
But you also don't want to write your
game three or four or five times over.